In this segment, we'll be
talking about how to obtain a
developer key to make YouTube
API calls and
run the sample code.
To do this, we'll need a
registered Google account.
The first thing we want
to do is browse at
a Google API console.
We can find this at
code.google.com/apis/console.
Or we can just search for
Google API console in a
favorite search engine.
We'll need to create
a project the first
time we open the site.
Projects are groupings of APIs,
and it may make sense
for us to create different
projects for every new
application that we write.
For running the sample code, we
only need one project and
one set of API keys.
After we enable our project,
we'll need
to enable some services.
Let's click through to Services
menu, if we're not
already on this page,
and scroll down.
We'll want to enable the YouTube
Data API and the
YouTube Analytics API first.
Let's toggle the YouTube Data
API from off to on.
The very first time we do this,
we're presented with the
Terms of Service.
We want to read the Terms of
Service and accept if we want
to be able to use the API.
Now, when we scroll down, we'll
see if the YouTube data
API has been accepted
and enabled.
We'll click On to also enable
the YouTube Analytics API.
The Search by Topic code sample
requires the use of
Freebase API, so we'll need
to enable that as well.
There's a separate Terms of
Service that we'll need to
read and accept.
Once this is done, we'll need
to access our API keys.
We can do this by clicking API
Access in the navigation menu.
There are two types
of API access--
simple and authorized.
If all we want to do a search
for videos, channels, and
playlists, all we need
is simple API access.
The key is already provides
to us in our project.
However, if we want to write
applications that can act on
behalf of users and upload
videos, manage playlist, or do
anything else that a user
can do when logged into
YouTube.com, we'll need to
create an OAuth 2.0 client ID
and secret pair.
We do this by clicking the
button that says Create an
OAuth 2.0 Client ID.
We'll need to give us
a product name.
We may want to update logo
and homepage URL.
Click Next when we're done.
Select Web Application.
We'll need to provide
a site or host name.
We can edit this later.
Since we're running sample
applications, we'll set it to
Local Host to point it
to our own computer.
Click Create Client
ID one more time.
Once this is done, we'll have
both a simple API key as well
as a client ID and secret pair
for making OAuth 2.0
authorized API calls.
Now let's go ahead and
run some sample code.